okay so let's get into the hydroxi
conversation you might have noticed that
for the last week or so Donald Trump and
Fox News have very abruptly stopped
talking about hydroxychloroquine
chloroquine the medication that both
Trump and Fox and some others and
right-wing media have been promoting for
weeks as if it's a miracle cure for
coronavirus and the reason they've
stopped talking about it mostly is that
more and more papers are being published
almost daily that show that not only
does hydroxychloroquine not appear to be
effective in treating coronavirus both
with and without as if Rome Ison the
z-pak as Trump likes to say it might
actually be causing more death now I
want to be ultra crystal clear here if
you watch this program if you listen to
my podcast if you know me at all you
know I am willing to accept anything
that works for coronavirus I don't care
if Trump was the first one to mention it
I don't care if Ivanka herself
synthesizes the treatment or cure
personally I want to treat people with
therapeutics a vaccine whatever works as
soon as humanly and safely possible I'm
putting all politics aside because
that's the most important thing but from
day one Trump and Fox were going crazy
promoting chloroquine as if it were a
miracle cure before we really knew that
much about it now I also want to remind
you that it wasn't wrong to hope
chloroquine could work we talked about
chloroquine before Trump ever mentioned
it I don't know if it was five days
before seven days nine days something
like that I told you about chloroquine
with us to throw Meissen without it what
what we did though is I came to you and
I said here's a bunch of stuff that is
being looked at we're looking at
chloroquine with and without as a throme
Ison we're looking at room des Vere made
by Gilead we're looking at favilla ver
which is also called a began that's a
Japanese drug we're looking at a
combination of two anti-hiv drugs there
are studies being done about could the
tuberculosis vaccine or the polio
vaccine work not as a vaccine but to
trigger the particular type of immune
response that might prevent someone or
it less likely that someone gets
infected with kovat 19 in the first
place
I mentioned to you dozens of things that
were being considered and that we should
look at scientifically soberly without
becoming emotionally attached to anyone
in particular but for weeks Trump and
Hannity and Fox were going crazy about
chloroquine remember this here's Hannity
talking about this is so irresponsible
prophylactic use of chloroquine with
other things mr. vice president I'm
holding up a letter and I'm gonna read
from it in a second from a doctor than
New York area and if I may read from it
he has now worked with his his
associates and he has a regimen
hydroxychloroquine 200 milligrams twice
a day five days as it throw myosin 500
milligrams once a day five days think
sulfate 220 milligrams once a day for
five days this is what he has seen him
and his team have now treated
approximately 350 patients and Kairos
Joel is an area of New York that was hit
particularly hard and another hundred
and fifty patients in other New York
areas his results we have had zero
deaths zero hospitalizations zero
intubations then of course Trump himself
pushing this wildly and I hope they use
the hydroxychloroquine and they can also
do it with Z FAC subject to your
doctor's approval and all of that but I
hope they use it because I'll tell you
what what do you have to lose in some
cases they're in bad shape what do you
have to lose except possibly your life
and I could play dozens of examples of
Trump saying this stuff I won't do it
today
imagine that you you just sat through 20
examples of that because they are out
there here's a doctor telling the blazes
Glenn Beck that the only reason people
are questioning the efficacy of
chloroquine is because Trump is pushing
it of course that's not true
here's a drug that's been around
literally forever hydroxychloroquine and
it is being treated like a pariah
do you believe that this is happening
because Donald Trump was behind it I
mentioned that is the reason
I absolutely think that's the reason I
think that that's why people are I have
been attacked when I've treated patients
with this and we've seen improvement in
the patient's well you might have
noticed that neither Trump nor Fox have
been mentioning chloroquine very much
unless someone else brings it up and
it's because many studies are finding
there's a really big risk to taking the
drug there's a new VA study of 368 or
386 male veterans and it found that 28%
of those glavine given chloroquine died
whereas only 11% of those who received
the standard of care without chloroquine
died it's not definitive but it doesn't
look particularly good it's not a
perfect study there's another study from
Brazil with similarly concerning
findings other studies are also finding
that there seems to be no measurable
positive effect from chloroquine and
there are people having serious heart
issues it's being tested both alone and
with as if throw Meissen when Trump was
promoting it you saw Fox News promoting
it constantly everyone has gone almost
completely silent with one exception
from this morning which I will get to in
a little bit so during week 1 of April
Fox News mentioned chloroquine a hundred
and ninety four times in the second week
of April Fox mentioned chloroquine a
hundred and thirty-eight times it
declined a little bit in the third week
of April Fox mentioned chloroquine 51
times and this week it is very very few
now you might say you know it looked
promising before so they mentioned it
now it's not looking as good so they're
not talking about it as much so
everything's fine that's not really the
issue though the issue is that they were
touting it before even with Hannity
saying you it could be taken
prophylactically when there was really
no more reason to push chloroquine than
a vegan or REM desi fear or whatever
else other then Trump was promoting it
like a miracle cure now they're not
really correcting the record they're
simply pretending it never happened
the right thing to do the responsible
thing to have done all along would have
been never touted as a miracle cure from
the beginning report on it as one of
many treat
that's being explored and now you can
continue to report on it and say we have
all these studies now that say it's not
working particularly well report
properly about this stuff without the
wild emotional propagandistic attachment
tomorrow's briefing it wouldn't shock me
to see trumpet lent chloroquine listen I
don't I'm not a doctor whatever it's
hydroxy what was that
that's a nasty question and you should
be ashamed of yourselves now they move
on to the next round of disinformation
and it's mostly about text testing
moving on from chloroquine altogether
now there was one notable clip about
chloroquine this morning on Fox News and
that's what I want to talk about next
I've got something really cool today the
first 500 people who see this video and
go to david pakman.com slash skill will
get a premium membership to Skillshare
for two months for free skill shares the
online learning community offering
thousands of classes on almost anything
you can imagine
everything's taught by experts the
classes get split up into bite-size
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me you can fit Skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and
that's not even scratching the surface I
got some great ideas from a recent class
I took called YouTube success and even
though we've been on YouTube for years I
still got a lot out of it they have
classes for every skill level whether
you want to get better at something
you're already experienced in or you
want to explore something totally new
and like I said the first 500 people who
see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
completely free premium membership for
two months giving you access to every
class Skillshare offers check it out I
put the link right underneath this video